practice running late yeah
sparks kid got himself stuck in the
bathroom how'd that happen well the
doors a push and he wasn't pulling look
at him out there Billy's my grandson oh
I'm so sorry yeah I mean not that he's
your grandson I just
i'ma stop talking now I'm messing with
you that one's mine over there Evan
oh it isn't that the coach's grandson
huh
so you must be coach Ballard's ex-wife
[Music]
margaritas what in and you'd love the
way I ran the PTA and you love the way I
show up at church we ought to go out for
drinks one night I'll give you my number
all right I'm around tomorrow if you're
free ah sure you should know something
though I'm kind of dating your
ex-husband you waited till now to tell
me you're sneaky I like that that is not
the feedback I usually get well since
we're being honest I know who you were
the whole time that's why I came over
here
damn nicely so we're still on for drinks
oh yeah
I just don't understand why you want to
go out with her you don't she seems like
fun oh yeah she is tell you marry her
and then you find her sleeping upside
down in the closet I mean seriously you
don't think that having drinks with my
ex-wife is a little weird you were
camping with John oh it was weird
trust me learn from me she spent 18
years with you I'd rather learn from her
dig and dig up a little dirt on me yeah
well let me spoil it then she's gonna
tell you about the time I had a little
too much to drink on Halloween and I
ended up puking in my son's candy bucket
no but she tells it better and there was
a time we had a fighting I locked her
out in the hailstorm damn but in my
defense when I locked her out it was
raining the hail was heaven-sent you're
a charmer so you didn't do anything you
regret when you were married Oh lots of
stuff feel free to grab a shovel and go
have some drinks with my dead husband oh
that's dark not as dark as my secrets
for you you you were so hot